[Music]  RadioShack is in big trouble  that's right sales are way down at  RadioShack and this week they announced  they'd be closing 200 more stores with  hundreds of stores closing thousands of  RadioShack employees will be released  now into the wild yeah they'll be  infesting our chorus will be putting  price tags on anything they can find  they create traffic problems wherever  they go if you keep pet food outside  you're asking for trouble just keep your  pet food inside the most humane thing to  do  lure them into a cage with a cheap pair  of earphones okay once their traps pay  them neuter them and then adopt them  that's the best thing to do employee  just curious how many did you adopt Andy  oh I didn't adopt them they adopted me  [Applause]  for you tonight so one of them is  getting away up into the ground hi kids  us keep an eye out handle ladies and  gentlemen don't scare him yeah okay  you